avec christophe prudhomme porte parole
de l'amuf l'association des médecins
urgentistes de france où il rejoint donc
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors
revalorisation à des salaires allègement
des 35 heures voilà on y est si j'ose
dire vous allez peut être me dire vous
que le gouvernement aurait pu prendre
ces mesures bien avant la crise il ne
l'a pas fait malgré la pression dans la
rue
et puis à hull que l'auditeur dans votre
titre est particulièrement inquiétant
j'ai bien lu les déclarations du
ministre à la santé ce matin au journal
du dimanche
écoutez c'est du sarkozy réchauffer
c'est travailler plus pour gagner plus
c'est pas exactement ce qu'on va
employer
il aurait été plus agréable que le
gouvernement en l'occurrence le chef de
l'état lors de sa visite vendredi à
pitié salpêtrière annonce effectivement
qu'ils s'étaient trompés que ce n'était
pas une prime qui nous étaient octroyés
mais bien une augmentation de salaire
mensuel de 300 euros en attendant qu'on
voit des gossip allegri le salaire dans
l'ensemble des catégories
voilà c'est parce qu'il a annoncé
vendredi ce qui élit dans l'appli manche
et l'ampli est particulièrement
inquiétant tiens c'est la remise en
cause des 35 heures ici on veut gagner
plus soit à travailler plus à leur
travail déjà beaucoup à l'hôpital et
surtout la première revendication c'est
surtout les emplois des créations
d'emplois massifs à l'hôpital dans les
ehpad dont nous avons besoin tout de
suite dit travailler plus pour gagner
plus
le mini de la santé lui a parlé d'
alléger les 35 heures mais lui coûter sa
cellule et le langage technocratique
c'est la langue de bois des politiques
alléger les 35 heures la phrase d'avant
rue devient madame le journal du
dimanche
c'est bien travailler plus pour gagner
plus voilà et donc je répète c'est
exactement les mêmes propos que nicolas
sarkozy pour nous c'est très inquiétant
c'est à dire qu'il ya des effets d
annonce nous verrons ce qui est mis sur
la table puisque monsieur verront
annonce un ségur de la santé le 25 de ce
mois
va falloir qu'ils viennent avec d'autres
propositions que celles qu'il a annoncé
dimanche et aujourd'hui il suffit pas de
faire son mea culpa comme ça a été
annoncé
ce qu'on veut c'est ce sont des réponses
concrètes aux revendications que nous
portons depuis un an des effectifs
supplémentaires 100 milles à l'hôpital
deux cent mille ans népal des
augmentations de salaires pour
l'ensemble des catégories
professionnelles des augmentations de
salaire et pas les primes et surtout pas
travailler plus pour gagner plus et
l'arrêt des fermetures de lits en
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire dans mon
hôpital pour mon hôpital on continue à
fermer des lits c'est à dire que les
plans qui avait été pris avant la crise
continue à s'appliquer dont contre le
sco et la réalité sur le terrain
il ya un grand écart il va falloir que
monsieur verrons je vous dis puisque
nous convoque à priori le 25 viennent
avec d'autres propositions est d'un
autre niveau que ce qu'il a annoncé
aujourd'hui dans le journal du dimanche
ou en fête le vin qui va faire suite au
mea culpa d'emmanuel mâcon vous y
faisiez presque allusions et maniema
cook a reconnu des erreurs sur la ligne
de conduite
face aux revendications des soignants ce
que le 25
ce sera la mort d'une réforme de la
santé en faveur des des hôpitaux mais je
ne sais pas voyez pour l'instant seuls
toujours sur leurs élites le régime de
la loi qui a été voté qui n'a pas été
approché la loi récente et 2022
les plans régionaux de santé qui prévoit
des fermetures de libéro structuration
sont toujours d'actualité et voyez juste
un exemple dans mon service
nous avons aujourd'hui des gens qui sont
encore en cdd et il n'est pas prévu de
les titulariser et les bas président
bush et le week-end dernier le week-end
dernier nous étions revenus à la
situation antérieure d'avant la crise
avec des patients qui n'étaient pas des
patients atteints par la maladie que
8,19 des patientes à fait classique avec
les maladies que l'on connaît qui
n'avait pas de lit qui était
hospitalisée sur des brancards
donc ce qu'il faut comprendre
aujourd'hui c'est que les discours avec
des bons mots moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas la contrition c'est pas de mea
culpa du président de la république
c'est qu'il nous fasse des propositions
précises chiffrées
il a su faire pour relancer l'économie
il a annoncé des chiffres x milliards
pour air france klm x milliards pour
l'industrie automobile
1 combien de milliards combien
d'embauchés pour l'hôpital on veut
maintenant du concret et que ça soit
écrit et non pas simplement annoncé lors
de visites médiatique toujours du même
hôpital d'ailleurs qui parlent plus
pauvres de france à la pitié salpêtrière
voilà donc le savez moi je suis je
travaille dans un département la seine
saint denis qui est le département qui a
eu plus de morts plus de force que le
haut-rhin et nous sommes le département
qu'avant le moignic hôpitaux rapporté à
la population est le moins de
réanimation rapporté à la population
c'est peut-être aussi une des raisons
pour lesquelles on a une surmortalité
bon on a un sentiment vous écoutant on
sent beaucoup de colère que tout tout
tout est à refaire que tout ne fait même
que commencer puisque il ya une
mobilisation peut-être mais joint ce que
vous confirmez
oui c'est même à vous messieurs à vous
le montrez vous avez montré l'emia les
images d'une mobilisation qui s'est plus
le genre de déconfinement à toulouse le
ce que nous lançons comme modalité
d'action c'est tous les mardis tous les
mardis une journée des mobilisations
pendant une demi-heure une heure dans
les hôpitaux on a pour la population a
bien de soutenir et peut-être en
fonction de l'évolution du déconfinement
la possibilité d'une grande journée
d'action à la mi juin pour se faire
entendre
parce que vous savez nous sommes
toujours avec les mêmes personnes
donc moi je veux bien que il faisait
changer de logiciel mais pour l'instant
pour l'instant nous n'avons que des
paroles et vous savez que le président
de la république vienne faire son mea
culpa après qu'il a annoncé ce qui est
la risée dans les hôpitaux
cette fameuse médaille vous savez la
médaille que l'on affiche aujourd'hui
sur les réseaux sociaux
celle explique areva ces huiles épingle
avec un tube de vaseline qu'on
s'accroche à la blouse aujourd'hui les
hôpitaux
merci beaucoup christophe prudhomme
rappelle que vous êtes porte-parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france merci à vous